every year the librarian of Congress
appoints a poet laureate consultant in
poetry it aims to raise the nation's
appreciation of poetry poets like Robert
Frost and Rita Dove once held this
prestigious position this fall Pulitzer
prize-winning poet and Princeton
professor her name is Tracy kay Smith
will begin her tenure as poet laureate
her work was featured as featured rather
a range of themes including fantasy
escapism and racial issues she was
selected by librarian Congress Carla
Hayden
aaden's responsibilities include
presiding of the largest library in the
world the Library of Congress holds more
than 164 million items in its collection
and adds more than 12,000 each working
day
Tracy K Smith and Carla Hayden join us
now for their first appearance together
welcome thank you so gotta be thrilled
by this we'll definitely I mean it's
such a great tradition of American
literary figures it's kind of in some
ways overwhelming to think that the
writers that have kind of made me want
to write now have something I have
something in common with so what does it
mean other than the honor of the thing
for you in terms of what you will do
with it well I'm really excited about
taking poetry and the conversations
about life that poetry Foster's to
different parts of the country and
listening to what people have to say
Carla is that the role of a poet
laureate yes the poet laureate is a
wonderful tradition that the Library of
Congress has had since 1951 and I have
to tell you though and we can reveal
this on live television that this was
one of the most exciting things being
the new librarian of Congress your first
one buy my first one Robert Frost and I
researched and I had experts helping me
in we book this was a big announcement
I'm making this call
and I've even had I had on extra makeup
but they were gonna take my taking your
fiction because we were going to tweet
this and I called Miss Smith and said
would you have the honor of being
librarian of Congress and there was this
silence mm-hmm I said oh
she said well could I think about it and
you're like nah but she really it was
really a reflection of how thoughtful
she is and what really spoke to me that
she examined things and she really makes
decisions and makes them relate Tracy
what was going on in your line on the
other side of that call because most
people would be going oh yeah yeah I was
trying to do that quietly I hope I also
said thank you I I was reeling you know
I had a certain amount of understandable
disbelief and I also wanted to think
about you know what what could I bring
to that position and you know what
what will it ask of me I wanted to think
about doing a great job promoting
something that I love and also I've got
one good idea which is make poetry
exciting to young people yes yeah I
think poach and some I have young
children and in some ways I really
believe that they are born loving poetry
and metaphor in the imagination and
somewhere along the educational process
they sometimes are made frightened of
what else the poem might be doing that
they're not automatically aware of it so
many times Tracy though people think
poetry is difficult or gasps boring and
for you it's not it's none of those
things yeah I think that sometimes
knowing you're going to have to take a
test and answer some set questions about
a poem can have this chilling effect but
when you're just reading a poem it's a
voice on a page saying come here this is
real this has happened this is how I
felt and it's hard not to feel welcomed
into that kind of encounter and also
it's hard not to recognize some aspects
of yourself or your own sense of
experience there I see you won the
Pulitzer Prize for poetry in 2002 and
your work your book life on Mars it's
been described by critics that makes
people cry you're mm it's the book was
written in 2011 you run the pote the
Pulitzer in 2012 it was about many of
the poems were about your father Floyd
William Smith a black man who grew up in
pre civil rights Alabama and went to
work on the Hubble tell us
go personal it's poetic I think so I
mean poetry in that case those poems
allowed me to reimagine my father who
had passed away
and to go back to moments when we were
together when he was real and in the
world and the poems closed some of the
distance that you know death had opened
up I think poems are good at closing all
kinds of distance and making us feel
like we have come into contact with
something why did you become a poet I
loved what poems did is for me as a
reader even as a child I loved the sound
of language and the sense of surprise
that poems could inspire you know a good
poem teaches you to look at the ordinary
world and see something completely new
within it and sometimes that feels like
a superpower and it only led you to meet
two librarian of Congress met her
through her words and I was one of those
students that said Oh poetry and that's
what I wanted to do with the poet
laureate position and making it
available and accessible and relatable
to people so that's been what I've been
doing since I was here last is we're
going to think of ways to correct Thank
You Tracie you have a beautiful voice oh
I love listening to your voice it's so
soothing
Lata go very nice congratulation
graduating yeah great to have you here
Oh Carl always good to see you as Paul
loved the Library of Congress oh my
goodness they're doing all kinds of
things and this was the capstone thank
you so much thank you thank you